[Music]
and traditional versus modern news well
I said that one different submitted by
an addict from Poland loves Jake ecru an
entreprenuer is offering one point four
five million to defeat Anna mama fighter
MMA fighters to defend the integrity of
traditional martial arts that's a lot of
money yo Joe sent this to me of a video
he was a Tai Chi guy right I will show
you that video take it away
video art is me cool take it away
Tiffany huh alright so there's there's a
multi-millionaire his name is Chen Sheng
and he founded a beverage and food
company to say guys know how even with a
millionaire he's offering ten million
yuan to anyone who could defend the
dignity of traditional martial arts and
so he's saying that it will be allotted
over five separate payments or matches
against Xue and so Liu Xiao dong he's an
MMA fighter and he's also a coach and a
fight promoter and we trained in
Humphrey combat so he's saying that
traditional martial arts is a fraud and
so he's saying that it's fake and that
he cracks down on fake things because
they are fake and fake things must be
eliminated no question that support from
all traditional martial arts give me the
stuff that he's taking away from like
muy Thai Subodh it's outdated and that
it's a lie without combat purposes
that's what he's claiming about
traditional martial arts so he ends up
fighting this Tai Chi master we is high
achievement to be combated think that's
more of a relaxing defensive thing isn't
it it is but it has combative roots but
then it kind of you know like a lot of
martial arts they kind of evolve over
time and it became more of like this
relaxing meditative exercise so this Tai
Chi masters and Wiley and this fight was
live-streamed for more than
1 million viewers Wow this was live
streams live stream do live stream a
million people watch comics and if you
get your ass beat in a live stream and
not getting posted on time
[Music]
yeah I know you you're the guys what is
a sp oh man the only one look like
they're the same age bracket let me
should opens the job with the fight it's
great why does what did he have a
statement afterwards so she did have
multiple reasons ranging from slipping
on a new pair of shoes with rubber shoes
oh god that was not to avoiding causing
a loss of life all mine feels too
dangerous so he laid himself down
because winning would cause this harmony
Oh what do you say to dangerous I
couldn't kill them but I did it I chose
the blockers [ __ ] with my head [ __ ]
that's so bad bro just [ __ ] in it you
want I think that also feels the MMA
fighter though where he's like see that
[ __ ] right there is exactly why I
want to [ __ ] these people up because
even when they lose they can't admit
that their discipline is inferior to
mine he thinks he's too dangerous makes
me want to whoop his ass again yeah
like when I first saw this clip I was so
hoping because I've seen it before right
and I was so hoping that you know the
Tai Chi I was going to keep the MMA
fighters ass but then like when I
watched it I'm like well they're not
even the same age group you know
obviously like the young guys
having a big advantage and then the fact
that you see the guy just kind of
pulverizing the guy in the ground that's
kind of hard to watch yeah and also to
Tai Chi like Huckabee could have been my
kickboxing savate you know something
like that and then we'll see how big of
a difference it is especially when they
do stand up well
zu he's been egging people on on rebo
like online saying like I challenge all
martial arts masters come and fight me
like you know like pretty much saying
like I'm better than anything else I
didn't this guy stepped up actually yeah
like who's down to challenge me and this
Tai Chi master was like I'll do it
I was good like hey way sit down let me
be a home yeah I'm just going to help
you out you just opinion pin your pajama
right now well are you going to sleep
okay
yes exactly what he does you said that
well don't step up to the plate in
wonder ten seconds you hahahaha why do
you think that he had a chance no I mean
I was so hoping he would have a chance
because I thought it was one of those
like quick baby videos you know where
it's like she gets old guy like keep the
dumb bad ass know the whole she'll wanna
see what you know what's happening right
but you know when I click on only I was
like damn it he said either I lost cuz I
didn't want to kill the loss of a life
interviewing out there he liked to have
on consciousness [ __ ] your activity
voice well he's looking for his teeth on
the floor I did one of his dishes killed
us she smiles all right guys oh God oh
man bill Chang the millionaire so he
wants to set up these five separate
matches against this MMA fighter and the
winner whether it be the MMA fighter or
the other person will pocket 1.5 million
yuan which is about two hundred eighteen
thousand dollars and the loser will
still be able to take home five hundred
thousand yuan which is about seventy two
thousand five hundred good yeah he says
that Chang is willing to allow MMA
fighter to take home millions if he does
win and he also says quote I want him to
understand he used this kind of
extremists provoked Chinese traditional
culture
and will need to pay the price hygiene
have used more for exercise and better
observation many of my friends practices
in China has millions of Taichi
aficionados are they saying all of this
is false I'd like for me like for me
like the Tai Chi guy coming up no side
to this extreme but it's like the guys
in the ring right and he goes an MMA
fighter I will [ __ ] anybody up and the
[ __ ] yoga instructor comes all right
brother stupid what I don't know the
preachy guy I was like what the [ __ ] my
why didn't anybody else step up to the
plate I just got to be shaolin kung fu a
Taekwondo guy like karate there's got to
be another traditional martial artist
that would come up but it's the least
expected of them oh that's a bummer
cause he doesn't in his own eyes he
didn't lose he said I slipped and I
didn't want to kill him I had Brendan
shoes man come on you know the Nikes
come on ders okay what I did see though
is a Conley made a post and opportunity
I don't know companies I'm a fighter and
he started off with traditional martial
arts and he's in movies and stuff now
but he made a post where he's going to
accept this guy's challenge so I would
love love love to see that fight if
you've ever seen kung Li kick somebody's
face in it is [ __ ] devastating he has
an amazing like back straight kick it's
[ __ ] crazy he did like a spinning
back straight kick they just obliterate
somebody like liver and kidneys that's
amazing
I know you said that this is going to be
split into like five matches is it five
matches with the same no is different
whoever wants to fill up to the plate so
it could be a different martial artist
but it has to be the same at a Thai
fighter
oh I see I hope Conley comes in and just
obliterates the pool I hope so because
yeah I haven't heard of welcome Lee but
they did mention other people in his
article saying like Tai Chi masters
losing and Wang Jean hi Shaolin
North Aichi so Shaolin Chinese boxer li
Shang
gende and a monk and renowned martial
artist I mean he along I thought I've
seen like a Shaolin boxing
and I could see that kind of standing up
because there's there are matches like
internationally where you see like a
Shaolin boxer like a look at the
kickboxer and I've seen them win
so there's it's actually quite practical
so I could see that happening but that
dude is kind of yoked so it can't be
something like Shaolin like mom with a
vegetarian or some [ __ ] factor you could
get [ __ ] up this guy yoke oh you
rewrite have them make a demo reel on
each one of the candidates first like
American Idol they're the viewers can
kind of text in so we can save another
Tai Chi it's different not because if we
saw like this guy's demo reel right and
he's [ __ ] biting chains crashing
turtle shells and [ __ ] punching and
refrigerators then you see a [ __ ] guy
at the park with EDM music and this is
the loot and this is his demo reel I
don't think anyone would ever text let's
get this guy to fight because it will
just try to save a life like I don't
even understand why there's like the one
Tai Chi master that'd be right and
there's three other ones are like I
could put him to sleep literally I see
what he did wrong yeah the third Chinese
wushu Association is saying that that
initial fight where they were throwing
down the gauntlet is what they're saying
that it violates martial arts ethics and
potentially the law they're saying quote
martial arts is a traditional Chinese
port as well as an excellent traditional
culture that includes various forms like
martial arts repertoire and free combat
we are strongly against such about
especially scuffles held in the name of
eliminating fake martial arts which are
more about fighting and pure
aggressiveness so they're just like only
a touch ambitious but that's what every
Chinese comes with movies it up it's
some guy that thinks is the new hot [ __ ]
and he's challenging every single sea
fool around thanks for watching just
kidding news guys don't forget to
comment down below we want to hear what
you say only if it's positive remember
that to watch more videos go up here
baby
[Music]